data professionals spend 80 percent of
their time searching for and preparing
the data they need
that leaves 20% for their actual work
the important jobs like analysis model
building and visualization efficient not
so much the problem rests with expensive
but unorganized data storage solutions
like data lakes the more data added the
harder it is to discover and manage so
enterprises aren't seeing sufficient
returns on their investments knowledge
workers who need access to specific data
types either aren't aware of it can't
find it
or can't access it because of its
sensitivity it isn't obvious what's
contained in the data lake nor where it
came from or how accurate it is this
makes that data useless IBM data
catalogue seeks to change this by
indexing metadata for easy search and
intelligent discovery of data sources
for analysis data catalog combines
cataloging discovery access and
governance all of which work together to
provide a 360 degree view of data for
data-driven businesses with its
cataloging and metadata features data
catalog makes it much easier for users
to search and discover data to uncover
insights and unlock knowledge data
catalog provides rule-based access to
data sets so departments can confidently
share data across silos which enables
users to interact with data in a
uniquely collaborative way users are
able to share new connections pipelines
and models securely fundamentally
changing the way users interact with
data though these capabilities
open up data discovery and access like
never before they're also equipped with
powerful governance tools in many fields
regulations and compliance requirements
demand restrictions on information
access rather than siloing data IBM data
catalog is built to modify who has
access to what information even down to
specific data being
per user per scenario this means that no
matter the team or the situation the
right people have access to the right
data at the right time without fearing a
breach of compliance security IBM data
catalog is an important cornerstone
Watson Data Platform it eliminates
barriers to data access while ensuring
every bit of information is securely
indexed classified accessible and
governed take back the 80 percent sign
up for your free trial today
you